وحش النقرصين في سماء اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
المانيا
بالفشل نعم لقد فجرتها موسكو بهذا الاعلان
بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
بين الامريكان واسرائيل والعرب يقاطعون
المنتجات السويديه والاقتصاد السويديا
الغرب وموسكو الى ساحه الحرب طال الانتظار
وكثره الطلبات والاستغاثات والمدن
الاوكرانيه تسقط هيا ايها الحنفاء لا
تتركون هل الاوكرانيون فهل من يلبي النداء
وبعد كل ذلك الالحاح يبدو ان اسارير زر
الاسكي وحكومته ستبتسم قليلا وسيتكشف ضيقه
برلين
وهو المستشار الالماني
تصديرها من الدول الشركه ايضا
وذلك بحسبه وكاله الانباء الى الالمانيه
الحكومه الالمانيه انها تهدف لتاسيس
كتيبتين دبابات ليبرتو من اجل اوكرانيا
تتضمن اربع عشره دبابه
لكن هل كله تلك الجلبه من اجل اربعه 10
دبابه فقط هي احفاد هتلر هذه المجموعه قد
يدمرها بوتن فور دخولها من حدود اوكرانيا
رد الرؤوس جاء على لسان متحدثين بمتر
بسكوه الذي قال ان تسليماكي الدبابات
ليبرده سيترك اثرا لا يمحى على العلاقه مع
برلين ولم ياتي بخير على علاقه المانيا
وروسيا مستقبلا لكن ماذا عن الجانب
الامريكي الولايات المتحده يتحدثون عن
سلاح جديد سيحل ضيفا ثقيلا على حرب روسيا
واكرانيا امريكا
[موسيقى]
النوويه لدخول المعارك مي تختبرت الدفاع
الروسيه اطلاق صواريخ زركون من الفرقاطه
ادمر القرشكوف مدني يصل ل 900 كم قالت
الوزاره الروسيه انها اجرت تدريبات على
صواريخ تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت ليستمر
الرد الروسي وهنا يعود بسكوف ليقوله ان
الخطه الغربيه محكوم عليها بالفشل لان ذلك
مبالغه في تقدير الامكانات التي ستضيفها
الدبابات للجيش الاوكراني مؤكدا ان هذه
الدبابات ستخترق مثل غيرها وهي بيضه الثمن
فحسب والتقوله اما في التلفزيون الروسي
الحكوميه قالوا انه ظهور الدبابات
الالمانيه في اوكرانيا
الاعتبار الاراضي الالمانيه والقواعد
العسكريه والمواقع الاخرى اهداف مشروعا
ليقولها فيدف صريحه في وجههم دعو صانعي
الساعات بيدن وشوز يوقفني دقات الساعه
الذريه لفتره من الوقت للقيام بذلك عليهما
ان يفهمها النساء سهمهما الاوكراني صدى
منذ فتره طويله وذلك وفق وسائل اعلام
روسيه وبعد معركه صعبه ما هو الجيش
الاوكراني يعلن انسحابه من بلده سوليدر
شرق البلاد بينما كانت روسيا قد اعلنت
سيطرتها على البلده قبل اسبوعين ولكن
انتقلت الحرب من سوليدر لتتحول الى حرب
الشوارع داخله احياء والشوارع مدينه
[موسيقى]
انسانيه الامميه وصلت الى محيط بلده شرق
اوكرانيا التي شهدت اشرس المعارك منذ
بدايه الغرب من جانبه الجيش الاوكراني
اجري تدريبات عسكريه في منطقه زبرجات
والمتحدث باسم الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
يقول ان روسيا عدلت في قيادتها العسكريه
وانها المرحله الاولى من التعبئه وبدات
التقدم نحو اوكرانيا استعدادا لهجوم قوي
لننتقل الى قمه تغيير وبعد تصاعدي حمله
الاقاله والاستقالات في اوكرانيا على
خلفيه نشر تقرير اعلاميه عن تومي فساد
تتعلق بشراء امدادات الجيش في اسعار مضافه
معلقه المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه ان ذلك عباره عن اعاده تقسيم
النفود من اوكرانيا الى بريطانيا
البريطانيه ساعدت مؤسسه مجموعه الروسيه
الملقب
اخي بوتن في التخيل على عقوبات فرضتها
لندن لتتمكن المجموعه من شن حمله على
عمليات اختراق لاكثر من 50 شركه وبكاله
حكوميه بريطانيه وذلك في عقب العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه لاوكرانيا وفقا ما ذكرته
صحيفه التايمز البريطاني وقالت الملصه لا
تعرفه هويه القراصنه الالكترونيه لكن ليس
لديها من يدعوها للشك في صحه المعلومات
الصين تخترق الجدران الاوروبيه
ليس كل ما يلمع ذهبا ولا كل الاجهزه
الالكترونيه امنه بعد اليوم في بريطانيا
تخشى كل ما يمكن للصينيين التدخل فيه لكن
الصين تدخل في صناعه كل شيء يا هؤلاء فا
الى اين المفر هنا وزراء بريطانيون يحذرون
من ان الصين لدي القدره على التجسس على
ملايين الاشخاص في بريطانيا من خلال سلاح
الرقائق الالكترونيه المدمجه في السيارات
والاجهزه المنزليه وحتى المصابيح
الكهربائيه بل هو معظم الاجهزه
الالكترونيه لتصف الرقائق الالكترونيه
وكذلك معرفه من يقابلون ومتى وفقا لتقرير
نشرته صحيفه تلغراف البريطانيه
الزعيم الكوري وحرب الظلام هذا تعصفه
صواريخها قليلا وترى عن الاعلام لبعض
الوقت لكن هل تستطيع وسائل الاعلام ان
تعمل دون ذكر الزعيم كوريا الشماليه
كوريا الجنوبيه تقولوا ان هناك اختارا
حكوميا ورده لدى جارتي الشماليه جاء فيه
ان كوريا الشماليه قرارات اغلاق العاصمه
لمده خمسه ايام بحسب كينجوز الكوريه
الجنوبيه وذكر الموقع الذي يرصده اخبارك
كوريا الشماليه ان الاختار لم يشر الى
فيروس كورونا لكنه اوضح ان السكان في
المدينه عليهم البقاء في منازلهم حتى
نهايه يوم الاحد ويجب ان يخضع لقياس درجه
الحراره اكثر من مره في اليوم الوطني
ان السكان العاصمه بداوا يخزنون السلعه
عالمي يبدو تحسبا لاجراءات اكثر صرامه
بحسب وكاله روتز وفي الوقت الذي لم تؤكد
فيه التقارير نوع المرض التنفسي الذي
تحدثت عنه السلطات الكوريه الا ان بعض
التقارير تشير الى تفشل جديد لفايروس
كورونا رغم ان الرئيس الكوري الشمالي
الانتصار على هذا المرض في بلاده فما الذي
يخطط له المجنون ولما كله هذا الغموض
الاحداث والتطورات
عسكريه ضخمه بين امريكا واسرائيل في البحر
المتوسط تحاكي ضرب ايران ملايين من
الناشطين على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يطلقون حمده لمقاطعه المنتجات السويديه
على حرق نسخه من المصحف الشريف يشهد
الاقتصاد السويدي اولا عاصفه ته كيانه
ويبدا بعد خسائر هنا الاردن وبرغم تعهدين
ياهو في عمان بنغفير يتحدى الاردن
ويؤكدونه مواصلاته اقتحام الاقصى كشف وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي السابق مايك بومبيو انا
الهند وباكستاني اقتربتان حرب النبويه
العام 2019 وان الولايات المتحده تدخلت
لتمنع التصيد في ذلك الوقت دبابات الغرب
ستغير واقع الحرب الاوكرانيه بحسب ما بعد
بها الاوكرانه بينما الروستودوا بحرقها
قبل وصولها فمن سيصلوا لغايته هو من سيفي
بوعده
[موسيقى]